So Val,
uh,
this is,
the course on foundations of modern social thought.
Uh,
it has a sociology number and political science number and the humanities
number.
And My name is Yvonne [inaudible].
I'm a professor of sociology and professor of political science and it is my
honor that I can introduce you,
uh,
to,
some of the founding
fathers.
I'm afraid they are,
or fathers,
uh,
mothers among them.
I will tell you why not,
uh,
of modern social thought.
Uh,
it's basically theories,
uh,
starting,
from the 16th century and ending up in the early 20th century.
This course is very interdisciplinary.
It's not accidental.
It has a humanities number,
uh,
political science number and the sociology number.
Um,
in effect,
as we started discussing,
uh,
the foundations of modern science in the 16th century,
that is even,
no distinction,
no sharp distinction between sciences and social sciences.
Right?
The first orchard on our list,
dormers hops did a lot of work on optics and has been in a violent controversy.
We,
they cry.
So those of you who are in natural sciences are probably familiar with they car
and his bio nearing work on optics.
Um,
John Locke,
for those of you who are spry to become a doctor,
I was actually studying medicine and performed a surgery on a very well known,
um,
uh,
English,
politician at quite a successful surgery.
Though even today,
doctors via don't know better.
These politicians survive because of good luck or because of the surgery.
Anyway,
the point I'm trying to make,
uh,
in the early,
you know,
uh,
16,
17,
18 centuries,
um,
uh,
sciences and social sciences are not separated from each other yet.
George Jacques Rousseau,
um,
a real pain in the neck,
but an extremely smart guy.
Um,
he also wrote an important book,
uh,
which dealt with sciences and social studies.
Um,
uh,
it's Sorta yellowy by the kind of late 18th century,
that people are beginning to identify as studying society or human behavior.
But even then,
until the very last orchard,
what we have here,
Emile Durkheim,
people identify themselves with a number of approaches,
disciplinary approaches,
they've,
or social scientist or write or philosophers or right.
The difference between philosophy and,
and social science is a very vague word.
So,
uh,
okay.
Um,
uh,
um,
they beginning to distinguish themselves,
uh,
increasingly,
or from sciences,
but they are still multidisciplinary.
Uh,
who is Karl Marx?
You know,
he is a philosopher.
He's an economist,
a,
he is a political scientist.
A sociologist named him as one of the founding fathers of sociology.
Max Faber.
Uh,
he identified himself as a,
as a legal theorist,
right?
Um,
he was studying economic history.
He,
I think primarily identified himself early in life as a,
as an economist,
as an economic historian.
Um,
at least early in life,
he began to call himself a sociologist.
So the point is this is a very interdisciplinary course.
Uh,
so one advantages of you to take this scores,
uh,
is,
that you will be getting more knowledge,
which leads you,
which would benefit you if you are studying sciences.
If you are,
if you want to become a psychologist,
if you become an economist or a political scientist or an anthropologist or a
philosopher,
I mean these lists of names,
right,
will appear on your reading list.
Okay?
So that's our been,
uh,
Ivo goal.
I have many,
many slides to show you and love.
You will try to bring them alive to you a little.
Um,
uh,
so I don't want to waste too much of my time,
to do rush through all of this.
But let me still speak to some of the details,
but I'm sure many of you aren't particularly insurance first about the readings.
Okay?
Uh,
and my first advice is don't let yourself to be scared by me.
Right?
Order readings are on the Internet.
You don't have to buy any books.
You don't have to go to the library,
you just to the Internet and you unload the readings and you can't claim the
reading south.
That's when you get scared because some of the readings are too long.
And some of the readings,
you start reading and you feel you don't understand the word of it.
Well you would experience is not very different from mine when I was reading
this text for the first time.
So my advice is don't get scared.
Right?
I don't expect you to do much more reading for discourse.
Uh,
in a done let's say five for six hours.
This will not be enough for you,
right?
In first leading to get the readings on your command.
I mean anything,
characters like hops or reading,
even characters like Nicha is a hard stuff to do.
My advice is that you kind of click creeds,
Kim Reed for the lecture,
do some reading for the lecture so you can come in with a sense of the text,
then I,
they'll give you a,
the most important citations and then interpretation.
And then I give you a searchlight.
You can go back to the text and you know what you are looking for.
Right.
And get ready for the discussion section at the discussion section.
I will keep my mouth shut and I want you to talk,
I will ask questions and we will have a lively discussion.
Right?
Um,
so by that time you really have to have more of a sense.
But I will use a lot of powerpoints,
right?
And the powerpoints,
we will be put on the Internet and will help you to go through the text.
So my first point is don't get scared with the readings.
Please don't drop this course because you said there are too many too difficult
readings.
This is not meant to be an easy course,
but I've,
you'll make it easy for you.
Okay.
Easy and fun.
You know,
you can't believe how Tomas hops can be fun,
but give me just one v thrive and you get to see how fun he is.
All right.
Now the other concern,
right?
People who shop assignments,
well,
there are quite a few assignments to discourse,
but I am one of those people who are scared of exams.
I was almost 70 when I got my driver's license because I did not want to fail.
We fail,
you know,
my diverse says so I understand anxieties about tests.
So therefore I had been versed in cards over my life to make assignments
serious.
Make sure that you put serious work into the course,
you mastered the material and at the same time the level of anxiety is reduced
near zero.
How do I do that?
Easy.
That'd be a B,
three tests.
All the three tests they'll be administered on the intern that you'll sit in
your room,
you sit in their library,
you go to a coffee shop,
you go to Starbucks and you login 8:00 PM on a given day and then you'll be able
to get questions from this.
You have to answer some of them,
right?
I also,
they'll give you a set of questions,
Vaughn v before the test,
so you will not be surprised what kind of questions you've,
you'll be asked Ibo,
reduce that list.
And either from this,
let's say I will give you a list of about eight to 10 questions.
They use it to three and then you will have to answer to,
okay.
But that'd be,
it'd be no anxiety if you don't know exactly what's going on.
You've,
you've have von hour.
Uh,
to answer it,
I don't mind.
You know,
if you prepare and you cut and paste and you put it on the Internet,
that's okay.
I used to open book.
You can use books.
What I want you to do,
not to use books,
I want to use your brain,
right?
Fletchy change.
Okay.
So that's the,
the three tests.
And then that will be one paper for the end of the course.
Uh,
the paper is not a big deal.
I just want to have to try to bring the course to gather different elements of
the course,
to gather the three tests.
Dot.
About three blocks of the courses.
The paper is supposed to link at least two blocks of discourses,
right?
Uh,
um,
and again,
you will be able to talk to me and you're teaching fellows about their paper
topic.
Um,
and let me then introduce our teaching assistants,
teaching fellows to introduce themselves.
We do do so.
Awesome.
Well,
you have that third bomb.
He didn't show,
uh,
and IVF takeover.
So two discussion sections.
Uh,
uh,
myself,
Ivo think a Monday and Wednesday a discussion,
um,
uh,
7:00 PM,
so sort of make sure that people,
uh,
don't,
don't overlap with other obligations.
Even athletes can't take it because practices are usually over and dinner is
over,
right?
So after dinner you can come do a nice after dinner conversation with me and ivy
will be grading the assignments of,
of students who take my discussion sections.
Um,
you can also be sure that we have,
you'll make all efforts that everybody will be able to get into a discussion
section.
So right now the crowd is bigger than the number of teaching fellows and myself,
we have so far on the Internet listed only five discussion sections.
But,
uh,
um,
if you want to take the course and you do not fit into any of the discussion
sections,
you will be talking to me and ivy,
we'll be figuring out that you will get your discussion section.
Not a single person should drop out of this course because there is no
discussion section that students are your teeth.
You have my virt 40.
Okay.
Um,
I think that's probably all,
um,
uh,
housekeeping.
Any question about this?
If yes,
please.
Loud.
Okay.
Well,
it looks like it's clear,
right?
Clear and,
and attractive.
Uh,
as just one very last sentence.
I don't want this to be a Mickey mouse course.
I want to be this to be serious,
right?
I want you to be challenged.
I want to you to think,
I want to do,
do you to read and I want to remember what you learned in,
in discourse,
right?
But I want to live a decrease the level of anxiety and make the workload
reasonable.
And if you come to lectures,
you can't discussion sections,
right?
It will be okay,
You will not be overloaded by work and you will not be a bit anxiety.
Now,
let me try to rush quickly suit with through of all of these orders and give you
at least a couple of words about every one so you get a sense what will happen
in discourse,
right?
And I have how many?
27 minutes to do that.
Uh,
so this is Tomas hops born in 1588.
well,
uh,
hops.
Uh,
had a little bit of a trouble child who,
a difficult father who was a man,
got into a fight with another clergy man and had to disappear.
He had a fight.
Thatcher in a cemetery we can in the 16th century was no,
no,
especially for clergy man.
Anyway,
he,
uh,
grew up,
with uh,
uncles.
Nevertheless,
he got to the University of Oxford.
They're pretty good and became a tutor and our beauty.
I'm Cavendish,
um,
and then traveled with him to Europe or France and Italy and he met Galileo and
was greatly influenced by Galileo at that time.
Um,
in English universities.
They were mainly teaching art historical,
um,
and a bell hops became very disenchanted with Aristotle,
the dogmatism of artists,
toto philosophy.
And he was an thrilled by the emergence of new positive science of art gallery
level represented.
Um,
then he can came back in England and that were very turbulent politics.
I've,
you're talking about this greater in the course.
And he was among dose.
He's a conservative guy if you are a republican UV love it.
Uh,
he sided with the kink against the parliament.
And since he did that,
uh,
he 19,
1640,
he better a Skift and van to France into exile and then returned in 51,
uh,
to England.
Um,
because he was a troublemaker.
He was not only in conflict with the Republicans,
he was also in conflict with the royalists.
Uh,
he died in 1679.
Now,
uh,
his first very cause a translation of [inaudible] he liked to kidney does
because he thought to kitty that short why democracy doesn't work right.
He's an absolute dist.
A hops are conservative,
right.
Absolutely.
List.
Um,
and then he wrote an interesting trilogy and this is again,
shows the unity of sciences and social sciences.
They'll try it.
The first volume deals with the human body,
the biology,
the second,
uh,
works with on the individual.
It is really psychology.
And the last one verse on society and Politics and he thinks the way how to
understand a human existence is start with bodily functions and more from body
functions to uh,
uh,
politics and philosophy.
And then his major work is Leviathan,
is the verb.
Probably most of you heard the title.
Um,
and this was actually at a time when Charles,
the first,
um,
Missourian had the executed,
and,
uh,
he actually was considering now shed should be a possibility to transfer loyalty
to a new ruler,
but the royalist fellow royal is,
or in exile in Paris,
didn't like,
so now he had to escape barriers to escape the anger of the royalists.
Uh,
this is the first edition of the Leviathan,
one of the most influential book in politics ever written.
Well,
I'm not a very attractive work.
Uh,
the main team is,
uh,
that in the state of nature,
naturally by human nature,
uh,
people are quite either,
and therefore ordered has to be imposed over people above each other.
Otherwise,
that would be a war ever.
We've,
we've would be in a state of war of everyone against everyone.
This is the major citation from Leviathan.
That's what everybody knows.
Right?
Okay.
John Locke is the next,
uh,
born,
half a century later.
Also a British scientist.
Um,
uh,
oh,
he came from a minor gentry family.
Uh,
he also studied the Oxford philosophy and as I said,
medicine was also a,
his second major.
Um,
early on he was very much attracted to hops.
Medan he met a major,
um,
a British politician Shaftsbury he con he performed the,
uh,
liver operation on him as humanity saving his life.
And then he changed course from our conservatives,
uh,
and became a sort of a republican or by America and political Sanders.
He shifted from the Republican Party to the Democratic Party.
That's what they did.
Right.
Um,
well
in fact,
he was even involved in 82 in a plot to overthrow absolutism and he had to
escape to the Netherlands,
returned in [inaudible] 89 to London and died a few years later.
Um,
well,
uh,
he's conservative work was in 64.
His address at the college in which actually offered the hopsy on theses King
Saul Gods and the people are beast.
But then he changed completely.
Uh,
he already writes an important paper on toleration,
Libero,
sassier reading yet.
Um,
and especially he rides a two treaties,
which is a major foundation work for modern democratic theory.
Major Foundation work for the American constitution as well.
This is the first edition of it.
So what are the main point?
Uh,
he said,
well,
men are born free and equal.
Uh,
and in the state of nature,
they are good.
That is a need for superior,
but a superior can also be accepted by the consent of everybody who is subjected
to authority.
Um,
and he is the first,
uh,
political theorist who advocates the separation of powers and has a major impact
to gather with [inaudible].
So on the foundation of the American constitution,
this is the American constitution comes from now.
We moved from,
um,
from uh,
England to France to Montesquieu who was a worn or delete a 17th century and
lived in the kind of order,
the swinging 18th century,
18th century was essentially,
at least in France,
fun to live in.
Uh,
well it was a lot of turbulence about interpersonal relationships were quite
interesting.
We'll say.
It reminds me of the 1960s,
you know,
hobbies,
um,
the hippies and whatever,
right?
Uh,
sort of before the French revolution,
you have the 1960s kind of stuff.
Now,
there was not Marty who ana,
but there was a lot of various kinds of sex,
right,
which made the,
made the 18th century quite fun.
And the life of Montesquieu maybe quite fun.
Now he was a born in the right ways,
knew more door where the good vine is grown.
Uh,
Brad,
uh,
his name was actually Sharis Louis the second.
Dot.
And he became Montez here when he,
his uncle died and inherited the title of Barone Dumont.
Montesquieu from him.
He studied the law.
Uh,
he's a major legal theories.
Any one of you who is adding to law school,
we will have to take this course because the theory of law,
right,
starts with Montesquieu,
right?
Any there he studied the,
uh,
at the University of Bordeaux and 28th,
he did the right thing,
you know,
to be in a parliamentarian in Bordeaux was boring.
And rather he did,
he went into commerce.
He became a vine merchant and the mercenary and that adventure spent two years
traveling all over in Europe and having lots of fun leaving his wife behind to
run the business.
Not Very nice of him.
So the money life was sending them money,
right to,
uh,
money orders or the equivalence of it,
wherever he was having fun,
you know,
in Italy or England or the Netherlands.
That was fun.
Uh,
then when he returned,
he began to do writing,
particularly,
uh,
his major book,
we are talking about antibody died in 55 about the very,
there are two major work,
the parish and lectures,
which is a fond of Eric and ironic feel,
a French and Persian.
Um,
uh,
for the life of Patty's,
in,
in the,
in the eyes of two Persian visitors,
a kind of ironic view of the absurdities of,
of French,
French life.
And then 48,
he writes,
find out his major book,
the spit.
It's off laws.
Um,
uh,
which,
um,
you know,
it's an extremely important book and you'll be able to read this is the first
audition off if you've your read from it.
What are the major contributions there?
As I mentioned already,
law book needed,
uh,
notice the need for the separation of powers about law,
separated only three branches of government,
the executive,
the legislative,
and once what he called the,
uh,
federative Montesquieu formulated the way how it is in the American
constitution,
right?
Namely,
he separates the legislative,
the executive and the judicial branch.
And we'll talk a great deal about this,
why it is so important to separate,
uh,
the jury difficult branch from the legislative and the executive.
And then,
uh,
he also did something very pioneering,
extremely naive v but very pioneering.
He looked at ecosystem,
right?
Here's the sort of the first environmentalist,
not quite even Khaldoon bid much before him,
but for a modern,
more contemporary theories,
it's really Montesquieu who tries to explain the nature of laws of eat a
climatic conditions,
looks at the interaction between nature and society and the two costs,
basically 300 years to realize how important this interaction is,
right?
So he's really doing some absolutely pathbreaking work.
Um,
now this is your show.
So,
I mean that I have many favorites among these people as long as Jacques Rousseau
is one of them.
Not because I disagree with everything what he said,
but he says it's so provocatively and it is in such a fun way that I just
cannot,
uh,
resist to enjoy it all the time.
He was born already in the 18th century and jr died just before the French
revolution,
though.
Played a big role paving the road to the French revolution about his life.
He was born in Geneva,
so he's Swiss a,
whatever it means.
Uh,
his father was a watchmaker,
uh,
and,
like Hopsin had a turbulent childhood.
Uh,
the father probably has some depth,
so he had to jump the boat and went to Istanbul and left his son behind.
Um,
uh,
who then in 28,
they move to Anansi,
uh,
France and met a wonderful lady and Mrs warrants will took Ian Young boys.
Uh,
right.
Um,
uh,
he was,
just about 16 at that time.
Um,
uh,
she was about 10 or 12 years,
his senior,
and they're alive.
You're talking about this more.
I will give you all this gossip,
um,
in,
in this course.
Um,
uh,
well it fascinated a lot of people.
Um,
uh,
later on these interests in relationship between John Sharp and Mrs Warren's
stone.
Uh,
uh,
um,
anybody remembers the name of the French novelist?
Um,
a rule Renoir,
uh,
rather,
and the black bell,
this is all that Italian destroyer of John [inaudible] who saw and Mrs warrants.
Well,
um,
the affair lasted for a long time.
Uh,
then he moved in 42 in Paris and he became a superstar,
you know,
wherever he was,
he had to be a superstar and he was a superstar in everything.
Uh,
it's,
uh,
I that is just no match.
Uh,
um,
probably Leo Nardo Da Vinci as somebody who,
who can become paired crew.
So in his,
as a renaissance man,
you know,
he knew everything and he did everything perfectly,
perfectly.
I mean,
or problematic now.
And 62,
he publishes two of his major books and Ivy,
we're talking about the middle of the glacier,
the big scandals.
They have to escape France because he will be big trouble with the church in
particular.
But in swizzle he doesn't get along very well either.
So then he goes to England,
return Slater to France,
um,
under an assumed name and died in 78.
Okay.
Uh,
about Rousseau's very kept,
uh,
the first one which I said is still dealing with sciences and social sciences.
Uh,
the disciplines are not separated from each other.
But let me also mention that in 52,
he rise in our para and United's a wonderful opera.
The dive into the lodge.
I have a CD of the opera and the five would know how to play music and I would
show you some of his music is great music.
Um,
more tart was so excited,
uh,
that he actually wrote an opera following Russo's upper.
He was in a big Viv,
we'll talk about this later.
I'm a bit,
uh,
um,
obsessed with music.
And anyway,
he was a big conflict with the greatest French composer ever Rom all,
I'm sure many of you know,
the vertical for our mall,
a great 18th century,
a musician.
There are,
it also was not quite as great a composer as a mall,
but,
uh,
um,
had a debate with him and his music was to be an alternative.
Grandma Rumble Vonda to write French music and Russo was committed to Italian.
You see Melodie beltcon too.
Right?
That's what he loved.
And that's what Mozart in most of his uppers loved.
That's my more south loved there were so rather than Rameau.
Right.
Okay.
And then second book,
discourse of origins of inequality.
Absolutely.
Great Book.
I don't have the time to work on this.
And then in 62,
the two big books video you will be reading from Ishmael and social contract,
Emile,
uh,
72,
some of the major themes,
uh,
I mean,
he writes about education or philosophy.
Those of you who are heading to education,
this book is a must,
right?
You cannot be right.
Uh,
an educationalist be south having read Emil cover to cover,
right?
This is the foundations of modern educational theory.
Um,
and he follows the life of a young adult.
A domain point is so Sattik corrupts pulls all the bad ideas in people's mind.
So the real reason of education is to get rid of education.
What people got,
well,
I don't have,
I can't quite have the ambitions to do it in this course now to get everything
what you learned so far out of your mind and to get the new ideas.
But that's what Rousseau thought.
Real education is.
Education is negative education,
uh,
probably wrong,
but very provocative idea,
right?
And then,
um,
uh,
he is the opposite of hops.
Nature is many.
Nature is good.
Um,
uh,
and foreshadows mark source.
So believe that now the social contract,
now the idea is that legitimate authority has to be authorized by those
subjected to authority.
Um,
and he advocated the first popular Suva Vanity,
right?
It has to be done by the majority of man.
He actually was not advocating a voting rights for women.
Yeah.
But at least voting last Rashford or man.
Uh,
but
he also suggested that individuals,
no,
only their own interest.
There must be a state which expresses the genital veal.
Vivi were talking about this a great deal later on.
Adam Smith's is the next one.
Again,
you want to be an icon icon.
[inaudible] you have to read the vast of nation cover to cover more than bonds,
right?
Otherwise you are not an economist,
so they will be dealing with Adam Smith's,
uh,
was born in 1723,
studied at the University of Glasgow and later on Oxford and became a professor
of logic and professor of moral philosophy.
Extremely interesting that uh,
the most utilitarian economists was at up professor of moral philosophy.
And in fact his first book is God,
the theory of moral sentiments.
It is about all about ethics rather than rational calculation.
Um,
um,
and then he travels in France matters or kind of people returns to Glasgow.
And finally 76 rise the book.
For those of you who are heading into business,
we'll have to read the valves of nations.
And you got in mind that the seat that is to Adam Smith one or who is,
uh,
talking about the self interested individuals.
All of us act rationally and the individuals acting pursuing stuff,
internist,
um,
uh,
fulfill social interest.
This is in the about in the theory of moral sentiments.
He is writing about sympathy is writing about the helping hand is racking up
thinking about God rather than just businesses self interest.
And that has been a library of literature,
whether that are uh,
Adam Smith's or whether this compliment each other.
And that is really volunteering and von good economic theory,
which is both ethical and the rational and calculative.
Okay.
And this is the verse of Nation.
Um,
uh,
Bell,
one big issue is about he promotes self interest,
right?
People shouldn't be acting out of self interest in order to achieve the common
good.
And people are the best judge of that interest,
not the government.
Right.
Well this is very much a question for today.
Um,
how scare form does he do,
do,
do we need the government to tell us but kind of health scare there?
Fourth,
we need Adam Smith's probably will say,
no,
you don't need the government.
You should judge for yourself what kind of,
how scale you want.
And then he develops the Labor theory of value,
uh,
that all value is created by labor.
He develops in an interesting way,
but for shadows,
uh,
Karl Marx later on and then,
of course he's known about the idea of the invisible hand.
While the invisible hand is not that obvious,
he uses the term three times in his work and or each time he's using in a
different and sense what it means simply,
uh,
the invisible hand is the free unregulated market.
That's how we normally understand it today.
Then he is using it as the hand of God and then he is actually using it as the
hand of Jupiter,
right as the bat hand as the faith.
So,
um,
video discussed this at great deal.
It's,
it's three of fun.
Ah,
okay.
Then John Stuart Mill and in fact,
uh,
how do you tailor who is a companion later wife,
very important for his room.
Now he was born in London,
uh,
um,
and it was actually brought up by Jeremy Bentham.
Um,
uh,
Jeremy Benton,
um,
uh,
is,
the,
the theory is to created what later was coined by John Stuart Mill
utilitarianism.
Uh,
the idea,
the central idea of Benton is,
um,
that,
uh,
Vr,
okay.
All of us seek pleasure and try to avoid pain.
That's what explains Human Behavior Utility is this is what we want to avoid.
And the correct action is to maximize pleasure,
minimize pain.
Uh,
now,
uh,
Neil had a nervous breakdown in 1926.
He found a Bantam theory too oppressive.
Um,
uh,
he met also Mrs. Hardy at Friedman who was married at that time and had an
interesting triangle,
uh,
Mr. Taylor and Mrs. Taylor and,
and meal until Mr. Taylor died and that's when they actually got married.
Um,
how do your tiller of,
was quite a feminist until the big impact,
uh,
on the thinking graph of Jon Stewart,
the mail.
How do you died?
Unfortunately,
very early.
Um,
uh,
um,
and the meal,
uh,
later on,
ruled his most important book after it had,
he had a desk,
but probably greatly influenced by Harriet Taylor.
Now he's very,
he established a utility Italian society,
but eventually became a revisionist.
Um,
um,
because,
uh,
explain it in a minute because he said that are really higher values,
which are also utilities rather than just a seeking pleasures.
Um,
uh,
he wrote the,
on liberty,
on utilitarianism,
and finally on the subjection of women.
Um,
uh,
the most important work is probably his work on subjection of the man,
which is a,
uh,
inspired many feminists even up to this day.
Um,
uh,
Eh,
he argued that women Antarctic actually worse in their conditions than slaves
because,
uh,
men expected in uneven love rather than just obedience and can least from slaves
they don't expect love.
That's the bottom line.
Then Karl Marx,
well,
uh,
was born in my 18,
18.
I studied the barn and Berlin,
uh,
I probably can rush through off his life,
probably better known than others.
Met with 44.
Frederick Engels.
Um,
I was expelled from France for revolutionary activities.
49.
He moves to London and became involved in politics.
Uh,
and,
uh,
then,
finally died in 1883 and his major works.
Patty's manuscripts,
you will be reading from young marks,
um,
uh,
about alienation,
the German ideology,
the foundations of what the Scots historical materialism,
the communist manifesto,
a band flat,
which is UV or read from it,
some steel interesting arguments.
And finally,
the major work,
the scrappy Tom,
this is a strappy towel.
And I just skip the rest of 'em.
Uh,
and go on to Frederick Nicha because I'm already running out of time now and
each of us 44,
um,
as a,
uh,
sign off a Lutheran Minister,
studied at the University of Bonn of what the vibe was.
A professor at Basel met,
became great friends with 300 Wagner then became bitter enemies liter on.
And I'd be like,
explained to you what is the reason of friendship and an arm is anonymous.
You see,
at the Burger,
he actually got a nervous breakdown,
uh,
and the last 10 years of his life he was just out of touch.
He was insane.
Um,
uh,
his major is,
what we will be discussing was it didn't make it seven.
It is the genealogy largely off models.
Um,
and again,
I've,
you'll have to skip a of Arthur.
His contributions are,
he is first,
first of the postmodern theorist he questions slide absolute rationality.
And a major bottom line is all knowledge is from a certain perspective,
including the moral values,
cannot be rooted in some universalistic principles.
Zigman fried and there's another auto vivia be dealing with.
Born in 5,600,
a very,
very long life.
Moved to Vienna.
I studied medicine.
Um,
and of course discovered psychoanalysis,
uh,
um,
and,
uh,
created the Viennese psychoanalytic society.
Still a major movement.
38 left lawn,
uh,
Vienna for London.
Uh,
his major versus the first one,
the studies on few stereo.
This is van psychoanalysis to be discovered.
The interpretation of Dean,
uh,
dreams in 88 [inaudible] on sexuality.
Um,
and the two papers,
what we will be reading from ego and ear and civilization and discontent.
Um,
again,
I,
I have,
you're just KIPP,
right?
Uh,
uh,
we'll put this on the internet.
A brief summary of ego and ed and civilization and discontent.
A just very briefly,
Max Faber,
I'm a German historian,
a legal theorist and sociologist born in Frankfurt,
uh,
studied at Heidelberg and Ausra.
Um,
uh,
had uh,
or nervous breakdown,
recovers it from
92 beginning to work on a religion and rice economy are so savvy,
right in 1920.
The major keys about UV or be reading the Protestant ethic and 1903 19 or four
and section soft is major unfinished work if kind of immune society.
Again,
I just skip and go to our last order.
Emil Durkheim,
a French social scientist.
I was born in 58 and as a son of a rabbi,
um,
but became an eighth Aisley,
turned on and re re converted back to religion as a New Jersey to later in life.
Uh,
was a professor and France,
the major we're excited about.
You've,
you'll be reading from the division of Labor.
Then the rules of sociological mattered.
His wonderful book,
the suicide.
Um,
and what you view might be reading from four is elementary form of religious
life.
So that's about the course.
And I hope very much.
I didn't scare you.
I've made you entrusted in it.
Ivo put the slides on an intranet so you can ski,
Ski Model,
Leisure.